hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to subnautica now I've
got a bit of a problem
and I'm not sure if it's just because
I'm so far away or if there's something
fundamentally wrong with my base down in
the ocean and it's been torn apart by
the mythical ghost Leviathan but um my
pron suit seems to be kind of funky
there I think that might have to do with
it being so far away that maybe the data
is getting Walsh it oh no oh no sir
Leviathan here oh boy well that's
problematic and possibly devastating oh
[ __ ] where's it going oh no is my base
okay okay anyway I'll figure that out
when I get there but I have a bad
feeling about that so I have a set thing
that I'm going to do I need to continue
to upgrade my base I need to build the
modification station and then as soon as
I do I'll have pretty much everything
that I need to be able to go forward in
the game and continue on with what I
need to do which is good stop that stop
I don't need it right now thank you okay
so once I go over here and once I figure
out everything that I do need I will
have all the resources and all the
necessary tools to be able to dive down
deep into the ocean and extract all the
wonderful lore and the deep wonderful
things in this final the final the final
base that the the the inhabiters of what
was that one oh god what was the one
this ship that crashed before us I can't
remember the name of it the crew members
of that ship they built one last base in
this biome where I currently am I don't
know where but I am going to find that
base and I'm going to extract the last
bits of story out of that sorry and then
I'm gonna continue on deep and down into
the dark areas of the Lost River now I
haven't been to the Lost River in a
while in fact the last time I went to
the Lost River
it wasn't even completed so when I go
down there it'll be an adventurous time
and I have no idea what's gonna be
waiting for me but I know it's probably
gonna be bad also for those of you who
are playing this game and for those of
you who have told me to delete the files
in the cache there's only one file
apparently that's causing a problem
because I deleted it I tried to do this
before and my my desktop crash oh and
the prom suit is fine it crashed
so the
whole game crash but there's one file if
you want to do this there is a file
called baked
- batch - cells - 14 - 18 - 15 . bin and
someone on the on the forums here
figured out everything their name is
board Jedi so thank you board Jedi for
figuring this out I'll put it up on the
screen here bake - batch cells 14 18 15
. bin if you delete only that file the
lag problem goes away
I went through all these biomes with
just barely any loading and everything
seems to be a hundred percent fine that
seems to be the issue it's in the
compiled octrees cache that's a little
information for you guys if you're
trying to play this gnome and you're
getting a lot of lag delete that file in
your savegame file if you don't know
where your savegame file is look that up
on google and you should figure it out
pretty easily it's in your Steam games
folder so yeah board Jedi thank you so
much for figuring that out now I need to
go get some stuff I need some Lube I
need more titanium not that much more
because I'm almost done with this but I
also need some silver so I'm gonna go
into this high okay then I'm gonna go
into this one and I'm gonna get up some
silver ore which is gonna be at
everything and once I get the
modification station one of the even
better things that I'm gonna be able to
have is I'm gonna make a storage
container under goddamn seamoth which
would be absolutely amazing I think that
was enough silver right there okay I got
enough are I tiny loop now all right
dude lit dude to do well I guess I won't
be getting any more messages from
friendly neighborhoods the Stars cuz
they're all dead
you know how that is you know they're
dead and all that gotcha hello friend
how are you doing stop looking at me
like that you know I gotta eat you you
know I got a mash up your body and turn
you into goop thank you for your
sacrifice to the Dersch bit of my body
yeah but the lags all gone so that's
actually kind of wonderful so yay it's
all better now
oh and my trees will be grown oh I'll
have everything that I need down there
it's gonna be von Dafoe okay so I got
that knee didn't yum yum
stop laughing you freakish [ __ ] just
stop it what did I just say [ __ ] stop
it's it's good I'm gonna make a titanium
ingot because I know I'm gonna need it
actually I'm gonna make another plasteel
bar because I know I'm gonna need that I
know for a fact I'm gonna need more
plasteel somebody's will get this now
shut up shut up I gotta go gather
resources you're such a son of a [ __ ]
just uh Oh God ah spending an evening
with Moni McGee yeah
exactly I want to spend my day oh boy oh
joy I spy with my little eyes some lube
a little bastards shoot shoot my whoo
music a little intense for some resource
gathering don't you think oh my god this
is so much better now that that files
been deleted and again here's the file
it's in your savegame file it's just
this one file that I think causes like a
memory leak it's a certain area in the
game that it has to remember but once it
happens it like slows down the entire
game because of some some problem that
it causes I don't know what but it's so
much better now
now I can actually enjoy the goddamn
ocean I remember I complimented after I
started this new game that I was just
like hey they fixed all the problems it
runs much smoother now but apparently
that one area still is enough [ __ ]
where's oh it's right there wait no no
it's not [ __ ] what okay am I going oh
god there you are Jesus Karen stop
hiding the seamoth on me I know you want
to creep up on me what again I need
Preparation I know I made a lot of Lube
but don't get excited about anything all
right so what do we got we got one
titanium one plasteel ingot two silver
ore we need table coral and then we need
a lot of titanium let's do this let's do
this I need four of you I need three of
you actually cuz I already have one who
do the deuce key okay got there I I need
to I'm titanium come on the fine to me
the goodies where's all the pieces of
screw yep there is all this grape you
can't hide your scrappy life from me all
their scrap that's big screen they got
two computer chips should have
everything else I need let's check yes
we do
you and no god [ __ ] damnit [ __ ] my
duck oh alright well I guess I'm if I
don't have lithium what happened to my
other lithium I thought I had lithium I
have lithium back at the other place god
damnit stuff stop making fun of me I'm a
daddy and I know love Karen goddamnit
I'm sorry I yelled at you baby let's do
this again oh no no no no no no and you
doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo
I love getting titanium won't have to do
this ever again didn't mean to makin
[ __ ] ingot I'm a [ __ ] idiot
don't don't poop on my goddamn titanium
Jesus Christ that [ __ ] happened here
give me that
oh wow good [ __ ] damn it's that bad
for you it's just a little poop god damn
it I lose anything nah got my lube
govern computer chips god dammit that's
a I lost some quarts
[ __ ] you and your [ __ ] boot bombs you
[ __ ] [ __ ] why is it that deadly
whose poop is that deadly that doesn't
make any sense whatever it doesn't
matter
it's alright it's okay don't worry about
it you're come with me a whole fish old
fish give me you give me you I'm hungry
I hate the [ __ ] ocean I hate the
[ __ ] ocean [ __ ] this [ __ ] place
god it's just a place of death desolate
death and poop monsters
that's all [ __ ] is give me some
goddamn titanium and then [ __ ] off I got
angry there I got angry didn't mean to
get angry I need oxygen cod I always
forget I don't know that's the most
basic thing in this game it's just it
[ __ ] oxygen breathe why don't you
[ __ ] breathe I don't do it I'm an
idiot I I know I know this God get get
the [ __ ] poop boy if you [ __ ]
booby-trapped your poopy trap my goddamn
C Mon ah Karen you couldn't come get me
you know make my life a little bit
easier you got it you're laughing at me
are
you're laughing that I died and
mysteriously respawned in this hellhole
that is subnautica the game that I love
a lot all right so I have the materials
that I need my problems are soon gonna
be non-existent they're gonna be gone
into the wind they're gonna be just gone
I'm gonna have a good time and
everyone's gonna love me and I mean not
everyone cuz everyone's dead remember
that remember how everyone's dead and
I'm alone in this desolate wasteland
that is an ocean oh yeah that's fun
that's a funny thought you know me being
alone in everyone being dead everyone
that I ever loved
probably had like you know family on
that ship the Aurora they're dead too
great cool glad that's that's a thought
in my head okay
boobity boo and we're good so we have
pretty much everything that we need I'm
gonna bring a couple dead batteries
because I'm gonna build a battery
charger when I get down there but just
not right now
but I should have absolutely everything
that I need to make the next phase of my
plan
blossom forth burst into fruition just
ex blowed out of my butthole and I will
get down there and do that so we're
going down there right now and then when
we get down there everything's gonna be
cool and hunky-dory ignore the fact that
I didn't get the first-aid kit from the
life pod and that take it with me down
into the desk
don't worry about that boy fine not
important all right oh there's my baby
oh there's my baby is so lag free and
wonderful I love the fact that this has
changed this is frickin awesome I also
love the fact this whoa oh I saw that
hey what were you doing out of your room
young man or excuse me were you off on a
bender oh I bet you were you rapscallion
you thank you baby
thank you Karen now I gotta build a
modification station Rach
right here which is where I put it last
time so why not build it this time yes
yes yes yes yes nothing doc prawn sue
ducked what am I gonna call you how to
call mr. miss I'm gonna call a mr.
Pfister okay let's get sculler in here
there we go mr. Pfister and bright red
oh boy
base color whoa Wow well I want to be
able to see it from a long ways off so
I'm gonna go with yellow and then you
know the interior oh I gotta I gotta
have a pleasant interior to look at so
how about her pool oh that's good stripe
let's get some bra vibrant blues let's
get some Oh yellow and blue is actually
a good combination maybe uh yeah there
we go yeah yeah that's good that's good
that's really good that's horrible
that's awful Oh God
oh no oh that's ugly oh boy oh no okay
but that's fine that's it's okay it's
all right oh I had extra titanium oh
good okay so I'm gonna get this I got
the plasteel so I get everything I need
to build the Pfister Meister which is
what I'm gonna need in the future so I
just go over here to the fabricator
proxied upgrades and we'll shoot
me oh [ __ ] yeah okay so I access the
upgrades over here I just gotta put this
bar oh [ __ ] yeah
can I put in the other arm hell yeah I
can no I'm gonna have a left arm mr.
Pfister has got the drill in the left
arm and the punch in the right don't
want you
Wham do okay so other than that we got
oh man what do we got huh we got a whole
bunch of stuff so I'm gonna per I want
to put all my base materials back in
here because I want to take this for a
goddamn spin I have been waiting a long
long long time to get this underway I
have been looking at this for just ages
and ages and Rousseff's ages so I'm
gonna take this one out for a spin baby
let's go mr. Pfister come on
oh that's hideous oh thanks Bob and we
are gone I'm gonna drill the [ __ ] out of
you I'm gonna drill the [ __ ] outta you
oh yes yeah oh it's drilling it oh oh oh
what happened where'd it go don't
explode away from me don't explode away
from me oh wait yeah I got I got a punch
it yeah I got it oh [ __ ] I'm falling
well oh there's more oh there's so much
more come here you oh I gotta grab it
with my right oh [ __ ]
well that didn't Oh God ah yeah okay so
I'm gonna go back I better put the drill
bit in the left hand and the grabby on
the right because it makes more sense
for me to grab with my left hand but
well I love so much oh it's perfect
everything I could have wanted come back
here come back goddamn it I got to go
over the precipice for this [ __ ] I
don't need this much courts but the fact
that there's just courts readily
available right here it's amazing oh I
love it I love it so much
oh god I gotta go find another
depository what is that ooh that's some
sort of material is that salt that's all
well let's find out let's grind it to a
pulp pal uh-oh
this saw trying to punch it huh yeah all
right good okay I need I need a big
deposit what is it gonna do to these
things hey excuse me give me your [ __ ]
sorry Bernie take that goal punch it
take that thank you
take it have it care for it what the
warper doesn't find me whatever it's
cool I could take him God drill that
Byam [ __ ] okay more quartz over there
yes you come here I'm gonna take you me
you're a nanite and what are you gold
copper what are you oh that's awesome
I'm grind you to a pulp [ __ ] okay what
are you what are you what are you what
the [ __ ] are you the [ __ ] did it go
whatever what am I looking at we're
looking at a cave what is this a cave
what oh that's scary oh oh this is very
scary oh no I don't want to be here oh
ah no no no oh god I fell through the
earth Oh No
okay now go to that cave oh that's a
cave of glitches oh that's a scary cave
for more than one reason okay well oh it
was no use copper ooh
infinite supply of copper I like it but
now I need titanium is what I act wha
[ __ ] [ __ ] did it again cop damn it
what's going on with this fairly this
this thing really likes to fall through
the floor was good Joe I guess grab some
of that oh boy oh boy
anyway it's possible to make a jetpack
upgrade for this thing which I made do
in the future because this is a bit it's
sluggish bit sluggish bit sluggish if I
do say so myself maybe if I just mind
the wall in general nope hey where did
my base go
I counted I lose it no it's right over
there
well [ __ ] it happen again happen again
happen again
whoa happen again whoa okay all right
it's gonna steadily adjust this thing
good vector it back in get in
Oh doh [ __ ] down we go apparently
oh well found more quartz think I'm in
the middle of the seat shredders path
but that's okay
grass again docking procedure initiated
see if it goes straight up into it I bet
it doesn't hi nope didn't didn't didn't
didn't didn't [ __ ] didn't oh boy
there's my target got hit I can do it I
got it locked on target locked on target
how does he nailed it couldn't have
picked a worse place for a base but
whatever it's okay alright so we got
that that's good we have that that's
great so what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna
get my materials back I'm gonna get my
lube back I am going to build I need I
need another I need another I need
another one of these I need another
multi-purpose room so what I'm gonna
need to do after I make this one is
probably make some bulkheads because I
don't have that and I need to make more
who base strength is very low Oh base
strength is very low oh boy okay so
gonna do this yeah but a boost key Debus
key need more foundation a lot more
Foundation whoa what the [ __ ] was that
something happened not sure what but
something happened okay that's fine
that's fine it's all kids kids kids it's
good it's good don't worry about it I
can't I got it okay base strength is a
little better all right I'll make some
bulkheads later but now I gotta make a
another bioreactor baby I baked another
one of these gonna make more trees gonna
make more stuff it's gonna be great it's
gonna be great Karen you go love it
Karen whoa another room to the moon pool
that's cool that's cool Karen I like
that Karen it's all connected now Karen
that's cool oh that is cool hey nice
nice mr. Pfister duct mr. Pfister is
docked isn't he
isn't he now I bet he is oye lantern
tree okay so I gotta make I gotta put
these these these okay get more trees
then I gotta make another I gotta make
another grow bed oh [ __ ] I'm not a
titanium really I'm out of titanium
really really really really all right so
that's good
I need to make Maura I'm gonna eat some
of these yum yum yum yum and then I'm
gonna put some of these in here to get
even more power going now this isn't
gonna be a reliable stream of power but
it is going to be some power which is
good and it's exactly what I need
because it's gonna provide me with three
power every eight seconds I believe I'm
pretty sure that's how that goes with
all three of them kicked up and running
I'm pretty sure nah that doesn't seem
right I don't know whatever it is it's
good it's better than what I had so I'm
not gonna complain about it okay so I
got titanium ingot plasteel bar what I
need to do is I need to make another
upgrade I don't know why this is all
like not good huh I could make a thermal
plant right now so I'm gonna try that I
don't know how hot the water is here but
it could be warm enough it's it's
possible I don't know if it'd be true
but it is warm water down here so it
might be true let me see
I mean is it making anything good
question I don't even know if it's
making anything because it's not exactly
on Maya it's not exactly on my thing so
let me uh put this um oh [ __ ] well I
should probably do something about that
should not yep link okay so what I'm
gonna do is I'm gonna put this over here
and see how that goes
put it right about there I got it Karen
thanks okay so I'm putting that there I
don't know what that's gonna do I can't
exactly interface with it's not exactly
telling me what kind of temperature
power it's reading there I mean there
are thermal vents around here but my
base just isn't near that yeah I don't
think it's nothing it's active no no
it's definitely not working okay so I am
all out of time for this episode I
wanted to
go down with the Power Suit but I'll
have to do that in the next episode but
before I go I'm gonna read these names
but these are names that I'm going to
put on the wall so don't worry about
these not going on the wall but I just
don't have the time to do it right now
and I'm at the end of the episode so
heady Ducker 33 says mark it hurts me so
much that you aren't taming a stalker
feed one peepers until it loves you
which I would love to do but I just
don't see the practical reason for it so
fire angel 20 said markiplier you should
build a thermal plant then you can get
powerup for your base lava spots around
the area and I want to do that but it's
just that I'm not close enough to one do
it Chris b56 said hey mark just a random
thought what if the disease in
subnautica has mutated from the one in
dead space which is interesting again
going on the whole dead space vibe of
subnautica I would like to think that
there's an alternate reality where the
two are connected but I'm not out
represent sure that's true so either way
thank you everybody so much for
commenting and thank you everybody so
much for watching and as always I will
see you in the next video bye bye
[Music]
[Music]